when Steve Jobs introduced the iPhone in
2007 Chinese labor cost about one US
dollar less than Thailand or the
Philippines and a bargain compared to
Malaysia
fast forward 15 years and wages have
increased nearly everywhere
but China is in a league of its own
by the time the iPhone 14 was released
last year the cost of Labor had gone
from one to eight dollars
today for the price of one hour of
Chinese labor you can buy 4.5 in Mexico
in fact the only major Latin American
economy with a higher cost is chilly
not only is made in China no longer
cheap globally speaking you might even
say it's expensive
so what's next for the world's Factory
sponsored by nebula the platform created
owned and loved by creators sign up for
exclusive early and bonus content and to
support polymatter directly
this is what two decades of cheap
T-shirts TVs and toys looks like
this is Walmart and Amazon and the
dollar store
on the left are people
you know about the one child policy but
you may not know what immediately
preceded it
Mao was convinced that a large
population was the best deterrent
against nuclear war
on his final visit to Moscow the
chairman bragged about the ease with
which his country could lose 300 million
people
so although children also known as free
Farm laborer are desirable in any
Agricultural Society in China this
incentive was inscribed in law
points which could be redeemed for food
were awarded based on the size of one's
family
surprise the population exploded
30 years later this is what China looked
like in the year 2000.
each rectangle represents an age group
for example 55 to 59 year olds
babies are at the bottom and seniors at
the top
the longer the rectangle the larger that
group
let's also add some historical context
the year each age cohort was born over
here
these 45 year olds in the year 2000 for
instance or born in 1955.
now the difference in size between these
rectangles may seem fairly minor
but see this minor difference between 25
to 29 year olds and 20 to 24 year olds
that represents 25 million people
as you can see by the large number of 25
to 34 year olds Mao's strength in
numbers Baby Boom was quite effective
and what's special about 25 to 34 year
olds
well they're what an economist might
classify as young dumb and broke
they've recently graduated and they're
hungry to start working even for low pay
and with poor conditions
in other words if you were trying to
unleash on the world an endless supply
of affordable toasters and cheap
T-shirts you could hardly have designed
a more perfect demographic structure
than early 2000s China
in summary your cheaply made iPhone 3G
was a distant Ripple of Mount zidong's
1960s plan to survive nuclear war
the second ingredient to this generation
of cheap mass-produced consumerism we
take for granted was migration
all those baby boomers were born in
rural communes way out in China's
Geographic equivalent of Montana
reaping the fruits of industrialization
required that they pack their bags and
travel hundreds of miles East toward the
urban Coast
between 1990 and 2010 10 million new
fresh-faced migrants made this journey
each and every year
and at this rate it's awfully hard to
imagine ever running out of Labor
but beneath these impressively large
numbers China was just going through the
same demographic transition as every
other country
in the first stage you have an
Agricultural Society
without the aid of tractors or
Harvesters or sprinklers there's only
enough food to survive if everyone
spends their time farming
and on the farm remember children are
free labor just don't expect to live
very long without modern medicine
lots of births lots of deaths China
during the cultural revolution
next you start building a few
rudimentary machines nothing fancy but
enough to allow a single farmer to
produce rice for say 1.1 people
then something magical happens someone
else's time is freed up to focus on
something like antibiotics
mortality goes down but fertility stays
High
China in the 70s and 80s
as time goes on more and more farmers
put down their shovels and moved to the
city
and in the city children turn from
valuable assets to expensive liabilities
fertility therefore starts to fall
[Music]
now for Simplicity imagine just three
groups of people kids adults and seniors
because mortality was until recently
High you don't yet have a lot of 80 and
90 year olds
because fertility was previously High
you now have lots of adults
and because fertility is currently very
low you don't have many kids
this is your country's golden
opportunity what's called a demographic
dividend
a few short decades where you have lots
of working age adults with few kids or
seniors to financially support
if you can put them all to work you can
ride this demographic wave all the way
to modernity
and that's exactly what China did
the only difference is that China's
demographic dividend happened on an
extremely condensed timeline
it ramped up incredibly quickly and is
now collapsing all at once
before Mao died here in 1976 he was
actively trying to expand the population
as quickly as possible
naturally 30 years later all those baby
boomers entered the labor market at the
same time
immediately after Mao died here the one
child policy made high fertility illegal
so today the labor market is suddenly
shrinking
for the last few decades only diaper
companies have felt this dearth of
children
economically speaking kids are pretty
useless
but today those kids are no longer kids
and their absence is an absence of Labor
remember those millions of extra 25 to
34 year olds in the year 2000
they're now on average 53 and rounding
the corner to retirement
what was once a demographic dividend has
become a deficit
needless to say China today is the
youngest it will likely ever be in our
lifetimes
if you're currently 20 and live to 90
you can plausibly expect to see its
total population decrease by about 40
percent
the rate of urbanization likewise can
only go as high as 100 percent
China is reaching what economists call
the Lewis Turning Point
the total number of Chinese workers
peaked back in 2015 and has declined
every year but won since
so where does this leave companies who
rely on this disappearing labor
in one of three categories
first if China is your primary Market
you might be inclined to stay
if not the question is do you require
skilled labor
if the answer is no your company left
China a long time ago
there's no reason to pay four times more
when you could move to say Mexico
especially given its proximity to
American consumers
just 21 percent of Nike footwear for
example is still made in China
finally by deduction it's safe to assume
that any company that hasn't left cares
about more than just cost
it helps that China has 62 million more
20 year olds than Vietnam has people
you can't beat its scale or flexibility
Apple can hire a small country's worth
of temporary workers right before the
next iPhone is released
infrastructure is also important
roads ports Bridges Chinese cities roll
out the red carpet after all the careers
of local bureaucrats depended on their
ability to attract businesses
now these companies have and will
diversify opening a few factories in
Vietnam or India but they won't leave
China until they're dragged kicking and
screaming
we know they can't easily Escape because
they just put up with three years of
lockdowns protests and travel
restrictions
Apple used to reserve 50 business class
tickets between San Francisco and
Shanghai per day
you didn't hear Tim Cook complaining
when those flights disappeared for a
thousand days
likewise although China's labor force is
in Decline its consumer Market is still
large and relatively untapped
Starbucks Walmart and McDonald's will
continue expanding not shrinking in the
country for the foreseeable future
that's what happens to companies
but what about China the country
previously the large working age
population kept the cost of Labor down
leading to increased profit
confident in its continued growth
companies then use that profit to invest
back in the country
but as the population begins to decrease
so too does foreign investment
that puts China in a tough position
its labor is too expensive to be
competitive on the low end but not
skilled enough to occupy the high end
this is called the middle income trap
and the only way out is education
greater skills equal higher wages and
those higher wages are spent on cars
phones and vacations
consumption that neatly replaces lost
investment
and man oh man does China have education
college enrollment tripled between 2000
and 2015.
performance on the GAO cow the college
entrance exam is less a score than an
identity
in the after school tutoring arms race
became so intense that the government
was forced to intervene
if China had a state religion it might
be education
the problem is not so much a shortage as
an uneven distribution
a tiny minority are extremely well
educated while the vast majority are
left behind
the country May churn out Bachelor
graduate and professional degrees but 70
percent lack even a high school
education
what it really needs is something in the
middle
these days even quote low skill factory
work requires skills those without a
high school diploma may be missing
meanwhile there are only so many
glamorous white-collar tech jobs the
kind Chinese college graduates were told
awaited them
in other words most of the labor force
either lacks the skills required of a
mechanic machine worker OR technician or
is unwilling to do what they see as
menial work
the result of this labor mismatch is
mass unemployment
last year the youth unemployment rate
reached nearly 20 percent
now China has been trying to tackle
these challenges since at least 2007
when when Zhao Bao announced the shift
to a consumption-driven economy but
little progress has been made since
Chinese household consumption as a share
of GDP for instance remains nearly half
that of the U.S or UK
for years the rise of China was
considered a near inevitability
magazine covers depicted giant dragons
smothering the globe
book covers portrayed red white and blue
eagles being trampled by giant red
pandas
increasingly however these predictions
resemble the anxious motivated and
sometimes xenophobic portrayals of the
Japanese economy in the 1980s
beneath these narratives was an implicit
assumption that China would continue on
its current trajectory
that the demographic Golden Age would
last forever that it would somehow be
miraculously unimpeded by the challenges
faced by every other country
but the simple fact is these are really
hard problems
investing in vocational schools is not
enough it also must reverse the stigma
which surrounds them
neither is convincing couples to Simply
have more children it has to make things
like Child Care affordable
and it can't just induce consumption it
has to address the root cause
unaffordable housing which swallows up
people's savings
it's no wonder that out of 101 countries
between 1960 and 2012 only a dozen or so
escaped the middle income trap
a more realistic preview of China's
future may lie in the actual fate of
Japan
still a large and influential economy
but severely constrained by fundamental
realities like a declining birth rate
in the meantime one of the most
fascinating products of late
globalization are China's highly
specialized Factory towns for example
the one town that produced most of the
world's Christmas decorations
another one bauto at one point produced
60 percent of the world's rare earth
metals and we explore its rise in this
episode of China actually my nebula
original series
you might be wondering why nebula the
answer is simple because it's ours
running a YouTube channel is like
renting a space in a mall
sure the mall brings us foot traffic and
for that we're grateful but we're also
at its mercy and our interests aren't
always aligned after all malls have many
tenants and advertisers to please
so a few years ago my Creator friends
and I decided to build our own Mall one
where our interests are aligned with
yours
on nebula our incentives are to design
the very best experience and produce the
very best content the end
content like real life floors modern
conflicts City beautifuls great cities
and nebula classes giving you a peek
behind the curtain of how some of your
favorite YouTube videos are made
last month the nebula team asked for
suggestions on Reddit and this year
we'll be adding features like playlists
better playback controls and loads of
other quality of life improvements
now normally nebula costs five dollars a
month but you can get it for just half
that with nebula classes included at no
extra charge by signing up for a year
with the link on screen or in the
description now
that's just two dollars and fifty cents
a month for loads of exclusive content
you'll love